Châu Ngai Bông chính tháng 11, 18, thành phố Hà Nội tổ chức khởi công câu trên hương đào.
Đây là một trong những dự án được thành phố khởi công và dịch kiện nghiệp bệnh mốt năm ngày xài phóng thủ đô.
Chào mừng đại hội đại biểu đàn bộ thành phố Hà Nội lên thứ 14,
tiến tới đại hội đại biểu vàn Quốc lên thứ 18 của đàn.
Dự án có điểm đồ từ Nán năm, trên hương đào, trên thánh tông, lấy thánh tông, thuộc địa bàn các phường,
gần năm, hai bà chương.
Dìm quối, kết nội về phố Winsun, thuộc phượng lông biên và bộ đề.
Chào mừng trăm sóng bị bệnh tỉ đồng.
Pàn chuyến bào của Bà Nú Sao, Nú Sao đề hiểu hồng, Nú Sao đề ta hồng và của liên,
và Nú Sao với đường Winsun được thích kết nội em thuận với đường hiện chạng và phố Hợp với Quy Hoi.
Vì được đầu tư xây dự câu trên hương đào, có vai trò quan trọng,
thuộc đệ quá trình đối thị hoa khu vực.
Tạo tin đề cho việc thực hiện chủ chương gián dân và giảm áp lực sau thông trong độ thiệt chúng tâm,
phố Hợp với chủ chương, định hưởng phát triển của đất nước,
kết nội giữa các đường chục chính sọng theo hai bởse hông,
hóa phần giảm tài cho câu chương dân, bính tuy.